with us a former conservative Health
secretary former chair of the NHS
Confederation hello to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
Consultants won a 35 pay rise as I was
saying to my colleague at world's
smallest violin for them or do they have
a point
well I think they have a point I'm not
sure quite clear 35 is obviously uh not
something the government's going to
agree to but I think the wider Point
here is that this the government's
facing a kind of slow-motion car crash
uh where it's got a developing disputes
with the Royal College of Nursing uh
with the junior doctors and now with the
senior doctors and it's it's blindingly
obvious you can't deliver health care
services without having your clinicians
on side so there's a priority for them
to address that these separate disputes
and avoid a kind of developing crisis in
the Health Service would you have given
um
uh doctors senior doctors consultants in
particular 35 pay rise when you were
Health secretary uh no I've already said
I don't think that's something that
should be that can be afforded but it
isn't in a sense it isn't what you think
or what I think or even what Steve
Barkley thinks the issue that that
government faces is that it can't
deliver health services without
clinicians and it's it's failing to
recruit and to retain the clinicians
that it needs partly not exclusively but
partly because of the pay Arrangements
that have seen the uh pay the the living
standards or the real pay of clinicians
across the health service for over the
last decade now that's an issue the
government needs to address
okay so if you wouldn't give them a
third pay rise what would you be doing
at the moment you say that you know
looking at the at their salaries and the
fact that it they have um dropped uh
Fallen significantly over the previous
decade nevertheless we are where we are
if you were in Steve Barkley's shoes
today what would you be doing well the
the most important thing to do is to
talk to them because you won't resolve
the dispute with the junior doctors or
the senior doctors or the nurses without
talking to them it's a problem that in
reality the Secretary of State and the
the uh staff representative leaders of
in the BMA and in the RCN it's a problem
they face together and they have to find
a way that allows the Health Service to
recruit and retain the staff that it
needs and we need to remember as well
this is not just a British problem there
is a worldwide shortage of doctor of
doctors and nurses and we don't live in
a closed economy this is not 1990s
Albania we have to ensure that the NHS
can recruit and motivate the people it
needs in an open in an open and
competitive Marketplace so as I say say
again it's not what you and I think it's
what the doctors and nurses think that
will help ultimately decide this
but how do you negotiate with the Union
when the leader of that Union I'm
talking about the RCN Pat Cullen says to
her members you should accept this offer
and then they reject it and as a result
we could find ourselves in a position
where nurses are once again going on
strike
well that is of course that that's part
of the problem uh that Pat Cullen faces
but also Steve Barkley faces it's not in
the interests of the Secretary of State
uh to be in a position where they can't
talk to staff representatives and and
believe that the any deal they can they
do is one that will stick it was bad
news for the Secretary of State uh when
Pat Cullen did a deal which he then
which her members are then rejected it
the people of course union leaders are
important people here but the most
important people are union members the
members of the RCN and the members of
the BNA and we have to consider the the
prime concern of the Secretary of State
needs to be to ensure to address the the
concerns of those of that membership
directly
um the Energy Secretary Grant Sharps
says um the decision by the RCN was
frankly rather confusing how would you
describe it I don't think it was
remotely confusing a proposal was made
and they rejected it I can't see how
that's confusing it's pretty
straightforward to me I think He
suggests is confusing because uh Pat
Cullen says one thing and our members
say another so it's almost impossible to
negotiate with them well but we live in
the real world uh the of course it would
have been easier and simpler if the deal
had gone through but it didn't and
that's not just Pat Cullen's problem
that's Steve Barkley's problem in order
to create it's no good just saying how
wonderful staff are that work in the
Health Service you need to be able to
demonstrate to those to the staff the
doctors and nurses and The Wider stuff
but these it's the doctors and ministers
who are the Prime Focus at the moment
you need to be able to enlist their
support and their commitment and and you
need to do that in a world where they
have options they don't have to work for
the NHS and the NHS needs to recognize
that and to deal directly with the
representatives of those people and make
it and address their concerns directly
uh quick thought before I let you go
we've heard from Andy Burnham of um
greater Manchester previously high up in
the labor party when they were in power
of course suggesting that proportional
representation is the way forward uh
come future general elections music to
your ears I'm guessing yeah you could
say that he and I have been exchanging
tweets on the subject over the weekend
I've often disagreed with Andy Burnham
in the past but I found myself actually
in very strong agreement with him about
proportional representation and also as
it happens on our common interest in
health services and on the importance of
uh devolved management and devolved
development of Health and Care Services